welcome to the future of life institute
podcast
i'm lucas perry today's episode is with
michael clare
and explores how the us department of
defense views and takes action on
climate change
this conversation is primarily centered
around michael's book all hell breaking
loose
in both this podcast and his book
michael does an
excellent job of making clear how
climate change will affect global
stability and functioning in our
lifetimes
through tons of examples of recent
climate-induced instabilities
i was also surprised to learn that
despite changes in administrations
the dod continued to pursue climate
change mitigation efforts
despite the trump administration's
actions to remove mention
and activism on climate change from the
federal government
so if you've ever had any doubts or if
the impact of climate change and
its significance has ever or does ever
feel
vague or fuzzy to you this podcast might
help remedy that
i'd also like to make a final call for
applications for the podcast producer
role
if you missed it we're currently hiring
for a podcast producer to work on the
editing production
publishing and analytics tracking of the
audio and visual content of this podcast
as the producer you would be working
directly with me and the fli outreach
team to help grow and evolve this
podcast
if you're interested in applying head
over to the careers tab on the
futureoflife.org homepage or follow the
link in the description
the application deadline is july 31st
with rolling applications accepted
thereafter until the role is filled
if you have any questions feel free to
reach out to social media
futureoflife.org michael clare is a
five colleges professor of peace and
world security studies
he serves on the board of directors of
the arms control association
and is a regular contributor to many
publications
including the nation tom dispatch and
mother jones
and is also a frequent columnist for
foreign policy in focus
claire has written 14 books and hundreds
of essays on issues of war and peace
resource competition and international
affairs
you can check out his work at
michaelclair.com
and with that i'm happy to present this
interview with michael
[Music]
claire
so to start things off here i'm curious
if you could explain at the
highest level how is it that the
pentagon views climate change and and
why is the pentagon interested in
climate change okay
so if you speak to people in the
military
they will tell you over and over again
that their top
concern is china china china china
followed by russia and then maybe north
korea
and iran and they spend their days
preparing for war
with china and those other countries
climate change intercedes in
into this conversation because
ultimately they believe that climate
change is going to degrade
their capacity to prepare for
and to fight china and other adversaries
down the road
that climate change is a complicating
factor
a distraction that will undermine their
ability to perform their military duties
and moreover they see that
the threat posed by climate change is
increasing exponentially over time
so the more they look into the future
they more
the more they see that climate change
will degrade their ability to carry out
what they see as their primary function
which is to prepare for war with china
and so it's in that sense that climate
change
is critical now uh you know then you go
down in the specific ways in which
climate change
is a problem but it's ultimately because
it will distract them from doing what
they see as their primary responsibility
i see so so there's a belief in the
validity of it in in the way in which it
will
basically exacerbate existing
difficulties and make
achieving more important objectives more
difficult
something like that climate change
they see as an intrusion
into their work work space
you know they're trained as soldiers
to uh carry out their military duties
which is uh you know combat related
and they believe that climate change is
very real
and getting uh more intense as time goes
on
and it's going to hold them back
intrude on their ability to
to carry out their combat functions is
going to be a
distraction on multiple levels it's
going to create
new kinds of conflicts uh that they
would rather not deal with it's going to
create emergencies around the world
humanitarian disasters at home and
abroad
all of these are going to suck away
resources time effort energy money
that they believe should be devoted to
uh you know their primary function of
preparing for war with with major
enemies
what would you say the um primary
interests of the pentagon are right now
other than than climate change
other than climate change well the the
u.s department of defense at this time
has
a number of crises going on
simultaneously
in addition to climate change there's
covet of course
like every other institution in u.s
society
the military was hampered
by covet many service
people came down with covid
and as some died and it forced
uh military operations to be restricted
ships had to be brought back to port
because uh
because uh covet broke out on ships
so that was a problem the military is
also addressing issues
of racism and extremism in the ranks
that's become a major problem right now
that they're
dealing with but they view climate
change
as the leading threat to national
security
of a non-military nature
so um would you add so you added so
china was one of the first things that
you mentioned
uh how would you also rank and relate
you know the space of the their their
considerations like uh russia and uh
nuclear north korea and iran
sure the department of defense
just released their budget for fiscal
year
2022 and they
they rank uh their military threats
and they say china is overwhelmingly
the number one threat to u.s national
security
followed by russia followed by
north korea and iran and then down the
list
would be terrorist threats like al qaeda
and isis but as you know
the administration has made a decision
to
leave afghanistan and to
downgrade u.s forces in that part of the
world
so fighting terrorism
an insurgency has been demoted
as a major threat's u.s security
and even russia has been demoted
to second place over the past few years
russia and china have been equated
but now china has been pushed ahead as
the number one threat
the term they use is the pacing
the pacing threat which is to say that
you know because china's the number one
threat we have to meet that threat
and if we can overcome china uh the us
could overcome
any other threat that might come along
but china is number one
so there's a sense of top concerns that
the department of defense has
and then this is all happening in a
context
of climate change which makes
achieving its objectives on each of
these
threats more and more difficult so
in the context of this interplay can can
you describe the objectives of
career officers at the pentagon and and
how it's related to and important for
how they consider and work with climate
change
sure uh so if you're an aspiring
general or admiral right now as i say
uh you're going to be talking about how
you're preparing your
units your division your
your uh ship your uh
air squadron to be better prepared to
fight china
but you also have to worry about what
they call the operating environment
the oe the operating environment in
which your forces
are going to be operating in and if
you're going to be operating in the
pacific
which means dealing with china you then
you have a whole set of worries
that emerges we have allies there that
we count on
japan south korea the philippines
these countries are highly vulnerable to
the effects of climate change
and are becoming more so uh very rapidly
moreover we have bases in those places
most of those bases air bases
and naval bases are at sea level
are very close to sea level and are
over and over again uh have been
assaulted by powerful typhoons
and have been disrupted have had to be
shut down for days
or weeks at a time and some of those
bases
like diego garcia in the indian ocean
for example
or the marianas islands are not going to
be viable
much longer because they're so close to
sea level
and sea level rise is just going to come
and swamp them
so from uh operating environment point
of view you have to be very aware
of the impacts of climate change
on the space in which you're going to
operate
so it seems like the
the concerns and objectives of career
officers
at the pentagon can be
distinguished in significant ways from
the
perspective and position of politicians
right so there's like some tension at
least between
um career officers or
the objectives of the pentagon in
relation to
how some constituencies of
the um american political parties are
skeptical of climate change
this was yes this was certainly
the case during the trump administration
because uh the commander-in-chief as one
of his titles
uh president trump uh for bad the
discussion of climate change and you
know he was a denier
he called it a hoax and he for bad and
any
conversation of that so the u.s military
did have a position on climate change
during the obama administration it had
as early as 2010 the department of
defense
stated that climate change posed a
a serious threat to u.s security
and was taking steps to address
that threat so when trump came along
all of that had to go underground uh it
didn't stop
uh but it the pentagon had to develop a
whole lot of
euphemisms like changing climate
or extreme weather events
all kinds of euphemisms used to describe
what they saw as climate change
but that didn't stop them from facing
the consequences of climate change
during the trump administration
uh u.s military bases in the u.s
suffered billions and billions of
dollars of damage from
hurricane michael up from uh
others uh that uh hit the east coast
in the gulf of mexico that did
tremendous damage
to a number of key us bases
uh so and the military is still having
to find the money
to pay for that damage
and the navy in particular
uh is deeply concerned that it's
major operating bases in the united
states
you know a navy base by definition is
going to be
at the ocean and many of these bases
are of a very low-lying areas
and already are being repeatedly flooded
at very high tides or when there are
storms
and the navy is very aware that
their ability to carry out their
missions
to to reinforce american forces either
in the atlantic or pacific
are at risk because of rising seas
and they had to
maneuver around trump uh
all during that that period uh
trying to protect their bases but
calling it by different names
you know calling the the uh the
danger they face uh by different names
right so there's this sense of um
trump essentially canceling mention
of climate change throughout the federal
government and its branches
and the pentagon responding by
quietly still responding to what they
see is a real threat
is there anything else you'd like to add
here about the obama to
trump transition that helps to really
paint the picture of
how the pentagon views climate change
and you know you know what it did
despite
uh attempts to suppress uh you know
thought and action around climate change
during the obama administration
as i say the department of defense
acknowledged the reality of climate
change
number one number two said it posed a
threat to u.s
national security and
as a result uh said that the department
of defense
had an obligation to
reduce its contribution to
climate change to to reduce its
emissions
and made all kinds of pledges
uh to that it was going to reduce its
consumption of fossil fuels
increase its reliance on renewable
energy begin constructing solar
arrays a lot of very ambitious goals
were announced
in the obama period and
although all of this was supposed to
stop when
trump came into office because he said
we're not going to do any more
any of this anymore in fact the pentagon
continued to
uh proceed with a lot of these
endeavors which were to
mitigate climate change but again
using different terminology
that this was about base reliance
self-reliance resiliency and so on not
mentioning climate change
but nonetheless continued to proceed
with efforts to actually
mitigate their impact on climate
all right so so so is there any sense in
which the the pentagon's view
of climate change is unique and and
could you also explain how it's
important and relevant for climate
change and also
the outcomes related to climate change
yes i think the pentagon's
the pentagon's view of climate change i
think is
very distinctive and not well
understood by the american public and
and that's why i think it's so
important um and that is that the the
department of defense sees climate
change
as the term they use is as a threat
multiplier you know they say look we
look out at the world
and part of our job is to forecast ahead
of time
where are threats going to emerge to u.s
security around the world
that's that's our job uh and to prepare
for those threats
and we see that climate change
is going to multiply threats
in areas of the world that are already
unstable that are already suffering
from uh scarcities of resources
where populations are divided
and where resources are at are
scarce and and contested
and that this is going to create a
multitude
of new challenges for the united states
and its allies
around the world so this
notion of a threat multiplier is very
much a part of the pentagon's
understanding of climate change what
they mean by that
is that societies are
vulnerable in many ways uh and
especially societies that are divided
along
ethnic and religious and racial lines as
so many societies
are and if resources
are scarce housing
water food jobs
whatever climate change is going to
exacerbate these divisions
within societies including american
society for that matter
but it's going to exacerbate divisions
around the world
and it's going to create a social
breakdown
and state collapse and the consequence
of state collapse
could include increased
pandemics for example and create and
contribute to the spread of disease
it's going to lead to mass migrations
and mass migrations are going to become
a pro
a growing problem for the u.s this is
evident
um you know the the uh
the influx of migrants on the amer
america's southern border
many of these people today are coming
from central america
and from an area that's suffering from
extreme drought
and where crop failure has become
widespread and people can't earn an
income and they're
fleeing to the united states in
desperation
well this is something the military has
been studying and talking about for a
long time
as a consequence of climate change
as an example of the ways in which
climate change is
is going to multiply uh schisms in
society and threats of all kinds
that ultimately will endanger the united
states but
but are going to fall on their shoulders
to cope with
and creating humanitarian disasters
and migratory problems
and as i say this is not what they view
as their primary responsibility
they they want to prepare for high-tech
warfare with china and russia
and they see all of this as a tremendous
distraction
which will undermine their ability to
defend the united states against
you know its primary adversaries so it's
multiplying the threats and dangers to
the united states on multiple levels
including and we have to talk about this
uh
threats to the homeland itself i think
one thing you do really well in your
book
is you give a lot of examples of
natural disasters that have occurred
recently
which will only increase with the
existence of climate change
as well as areas which are already
experiencing climate change and
and and you give lots of examples about
how that increases stress in the region
before we move on to those examples i
just want to
more clearly lay out all the ways in
which
climate change just makes everything
worse right so there's the sense in
which it
it stresses everything that is already
stressed
everything basically becomes more
difficult and challenging
and so you mentioned things like mass
migration
the increase of disease and pandemics uh
the increase
of terrorism in destabilized regions
uh states may begin to collapse there is
the
again this this uh idea of threat
multiplication
so um everything that's already bad gets
worse there's a loss of food water
and shelter instability there's an
increase in natural disasters from
more and more extreme weather this all
leads to
more resource competition and also
energy crises as rivers dry up and
electric
dams stop working and um
the energy grid gets like taxed more and
more
due to the extreme weather so is there
anything else you'd like to add here in
terms of
the specific ways in which things get
worse and worse from the
factor of threat multiplication
you know then you start getting kind of
specific
uh about uh particular
places that could be affected uh and the
pentagon
uh would say well you know this is first
gonna happen
in the most vulnerable societies
poor countries central america
north africa places like that where
society is already divided poor
um and capacity to cope with disaster is
very low
so climate change will come along and
conditions will deteriorate and the
state
is unable to cope and you have
breakdown and you have these migrations
but they
also worry that as time goes on
and climate change intensifies
that a bigger and bigger or richer and
richer and more important states
will begin to disintegrate and
some of these states are very important
to u.s security
and some of them have nuclear weapons
and then then you have really serious
dangers
for example uh they worry a great deal
about pakistan
pakistan is a nuclear-armed country it's
also deeply divided along
ethnic and religious lines
and it has multiple vulnerabilities to
climate change
it goes between extremes of water
scarcity
which will increase as the himalayan
glaciers
uh disappear but also we know that
monsoons are likely to become more
erratic
and more destructive with more flooding
all of these oppose great threats
to the ability of
pakistan government and
and society to cope with all of its
internal divisions
which are already severe to begin with
and
what happens when pakistan experiences
state collapse and nuclear weapons begin
to disappear into the hands
of the taliban or or to forces close to
the taliban
then you have a level of worry and
concern
much greater than anything we've been
talking about before and this is
something that the pentagon has started
to worry about
and to develop contingency plans for
um and there are there are other
examples
of uh this level of
of a potential threat
arising from bigger and more powerful
states disintegrating
saudi arabia is at risk nigeria is at
risk
the philippines the major ally in the
pacific is at
extreme risk from rising waters
and extreme storms and i can
continue but from a strategic point of
view this starts getting very worrisome
for the department of defense
could you also paint a little bit of a
picture of how climate change will
exacerbate the conditions between
pakistan
india and china especially given that
they're all nuclear
states nuclear weapons states absolutely
uh and this all goes back to water
and and and many of us uh
view uh water scarcity as
as the uh greatest danger
arising from climate change in many
parts of the world
in the case of india china pakistan
not to mention a whole host of other
countries depend very heavily
on water on rivers that originate
in the himalayan mountains and draw
a fair percentage of their water from
the melting of the himalayan glaciers
and these glaciers are disappearing at a
very rapid rate
and are expected to lose a very large
percentage of their mass
by the end of this century due to
warming temperatures
and this means that these critical
rivers
that are shared by these countries
uh the indus river shared by india and
pakistan
the brahmaputra river shared by india
and china
these rivers which are
provide the water for irrigation for
hundreds of millions of people
if not billions of people depend on
these rivers
the mekong is another that
as the supply of these water supply
begins to diminish
this is going to exacerbate border
disputes
all of these countries india and china
india and pakistan have border and
territorial disputes
they have very restive agricultural
populations
uh to start with that
that water scarcity is going to be the
tipping point that
will produce massive uh local
uh violence uh that will lead to
conflict between these countries and all
of them nuclear-armed
so to paint a little bit more of a
picture of these historical examples
of states essentially failing to be able
to respond to
climate events and the kind of
destructive
force that was to society and
to the status of
humanitarian conditions and the
increasing need for humanitarian
operations so can you describe what
happened
in tacloban for example
as well as uh what is going on in the uh
nigerian region so
uh tacloban is a major
uh city on the island of leyte in the
philippines
and it was a direct hit suffered a
direct hit from
typhoon haiyan in 2013.
this was this was the most powerful
typhoon to make landfall
up until that point an extremely
powerful storm
that uh created millions of homeless
in the philippines many people perished
but but uh tacloban was at the forefront
of this
um a city of several hundred thousand
um many poor people living in
low-lying areas at the at the forefront
of this storm
the storm surge was
10 or 20 feet high that just over
overwhelmed these low-lying shanty towns
flooded them thousands of people
died right away though the entire
infrastructure of the city
collapsed was destroyed hospitals
everything food ran out water ran out
and there was a
element of despair and chaos
the philippine government was proved
incapable of doing anything
and president obama ordered
the u.s pacific command to provide
emergency assistance
and it sent almost the entire u.s
pacific fleet
to tacloban to provide emergency
assistance on
on the scale of a major war you know
aircraft carrier
dozens of warships hundreds of planes
thousands of troops to provide
assistance now was a
wonderful sign of u.s
aid there are a number of
elements of this crisis that are worthy
of mention
in addition to all of this one
was the fact that there was
anti-government rioting
because of the failure of the local
authorities to provide assistance
or or to provide it only to wealthy
people in the town
and this is so often a characteristic of
these disasters
that assistance is not
provided equitably and and
the same thing was seen with hurricane
katrina in new orleans
and this then becomes a new source of
conflict
if when when a disaster occurs
and you do not have equitable
uh equitable emergency response
and some people are denied help and
others
are provided assistance you're setting
up
you're setting the stage for future
conflicts and anti-government violence
which is what
happened in tacloban um
and the u.s military had to intercede
uh to calm things down um and
this is something that uh has altered
u.s
thinking about humanitarian assistance
because now they understand that it's
not just going to be handing out food
and water
it's also going to mean playing the role
of a government
local government and providing police
assistance
and mediating disputes and
providing law and order not just
in foreign countries but in the united
states itself
and that's proved to be the case in
houston with hurricane harvey
in 2017 and in the philip in
puerto rico with hurricane maria when
local authorities simply disappeared or
or
uh broke down and the military had to
step
in and play the role of government
which is comes back to uh what i've been
saying all along
from the military's point of view this
is not what they were trained to do
this is not what they want to do and
they view this as a distraction
from their primary military function
so you know here's the pacific fleet
engaging in this very complex emergency
in the philippines
uh and what what if there were a crisis
with china that would break out uh
you know we the whole force would would
have been immobilized
at that time and this is the kind of
worry
that they have that climate change is
going to create
these complex emergencies they call them
or complex disasters uh that are going
to require
not just you know a quick in and out
kind of situation but a permanent or
semi-permanent involvement in a disaster
area and to provide services
for which the military is not adequately
prepared
but they see that climate change
increasingly
will force them to play this kind of
role
and thereby distracting them from what
they see as their more important mission
right so there's a sense of the military
increasingly being deployed in
areas to provide humanitarian assistance
it's
obvious why that would be important and
needed domestically for
in the united states in its territories
can you explain why the military
is incentivized or interested in
providing global humanitarian assistance
this has always been part of american
foreign policy american diplomacy
you know winning friends winning over
friends and
allies uh so it's par it's partly to
make the united states look
good particularly when other countries
are not capable of doing that you know
we're the one
one country that that has that kind of
global naval
capacity to go anywhere and do that sort
of thing
so it's a little bit a matter of of
showing off
our uh capacity but it's
also in the case of the philippines
you know the philippines plays a
strategic role
in u.s planning for conflicts in the
pacific
uh it it it is seen
as a valuable ally in any future
conflict with china
and therefore its stability matters to
the united states
and the cooperation
of the philippine government is
considered important
and access to bases in the philippines
for example is considered important to
the u.s
so the fact that key
allies of of the us in the pacific
and the middle east and europe are at
risk of collapsing due to climate change
uh poses a threat to the str the
whole strategic planning of the u.s
which is to fight
wars over there in the forward area of
operations off the coast of china
or you know off of
russian territory so we're very
reliant on the stability
and the capacity of key allies
in these in these areas so providing
humanitarian and
assistance and disaster relief is
a part of a larger strategy of
reliance on key allies in strategic
parts of the world
can you also explain the conditions in
nigeria and how climate change has
exacerbated those conditions and and how
this fits into
the pentagon's perspective and interest
in the issue
so nigeria is another country that
has strategic significance for the us
not perhaps on the same scale as
a pakistan or japan
but still important nigeria is a leading
oil producer
not as important as it once was perhaps
but
nonetheless important but nigeria is
also
a key player in peacekeeping operations
throughout
africa and because the us doesn't want
to play that role
itself it relies on nigeria for
peacekeeping
troops in many parts of africa
and nigeria occupies a keep a key
piece of territory in
central africa uh which is it's
surrounded by
countries which are much more fragile
and and are threatened by
terrorist organizations so nigeria's
stability
is very important in in this larger
picture
and in fact nigeria itself is
at risk uh from terrorist movements
uh especially boko haram and
and in splinter groups which uh
are continue to reign havoc
uh wreak havoc uh in northern nigeria
despite
years of effort by the nigerian
government to crush boko haram
it's still a powerful force and
partly this is due to climate change
the boko haram operates in
areas around lake chad which is
now a a small
sliver of what it once was uh it has
greatly diminished in size
because of global warming and water
mismanagement
and so the farmers and fisher folk whose
livelihood
depended on lake chad has all been
decimated
many of them have become impoverished
the nigerian government has proved inept
and incapable of providing for their
needs
and many of these people have therefore
fallen prey to
the appeals of recruitment by boko haram
young men without jobs so
climate change is facilitating is
fueling the persistence of
of groups like boko haram and other
terrorist groups
in nigeria but that's only part of the
picture
there's also growing conflict between
uh pastoralists uh the these
are herders cattle herders whose
lands are being devastated by
desertification the the
in the sahel region the the southern
fringe of the sahara
is expanding with climate change
and driving these uh pastoralists
into into areas occupied by
uh these are all muslim the pastoralists
are primarily muslims
they're moving into lands occupied by
christians
mainly christian farmers and there's
been
terrible violence in the past few years
many hundreds of thousands of people
displaced
again inept nigerian response
um and and so you know i could go on
there's
there's violence in the nigerian delta
region
uh the niger delta uh area in the south
and in the area uh
their breakaway provinces so nigeria is
at
risk permanent risk of breaking apart
and uh the us's provides a lot of
military aid to nigeria and
and provides training so the us
is involved in this country and
faces uh a possibility of greater
greater um disequilibrium and greater
u.s
involvement right so i think this does a
really good job of painting the picture
of of this factor of threat
multiplication
from climate change right so climate
change makes getting
food water and shelter more difficult
there's more extreme weather which
makes those things more difficult which
increases stability
and for places that are already not that
stable
they get a lot more unstable and then
states begin to collapse and you get
terrorism and then you get mass
migration
and then there's more disease spreading
so you get
conditions for increased pandemics you
know whether it's
in nigeria or pakistan and
india or the philippines or the united
states and
china and russia everything just
keeps getting you know worse and worse
and more difficult and challenging with
with climate change um so
could you describe the the ladder of
escalation of
climate change related issues for for
the military and how that fits into all
this
well now this this is an expression that
i
made up uh to try to put this
in some kind of context um
drawing on the ladder of escalation from
the nuclear era
when the military talked about
you know the escalation of conflict from
a
skirmish to a small war to a big war
to the first use of nuclear weapons to
all out nuclear war
that was the latter of escalation
of the nuclear age and what i
see happening is is something of a
similar nature
where at present uh
we're still dealing uh mainly
with these threat multiplying
conditions occurring in the smaller and
weaker states of
africa chad niger
sudan and countries and the
central american countries nicaragua
and el salvador where where you see all
of these conditions
developing but not posing a threat to
uh to the central core of
of of the major powers but
as climate change advances um
the military expects and us intelligence
agencies expect
as i indicated that larger
stronger richer states will
experience the same kinds of
consequences and dangers and
uh begin to experience this kind of
state disintegration
so uh the the
what we're seeing in places like chad
in niger which involves this skirmishing
between um insurgents
terrorists and and other factions
in which the us is playing a remote role
it's playing a role but it's remote
to situations where a pakistan collapses
and nigeria collapses the saudi arabia
collapses
would require a much greater involvement
by american forces on a much larger
scale
and that would be the the next uh
step up a ladder of escalation
arising from climate change and then you
have the possibility
as i indicated where nuclear armed
states
would engage in conflict would be drawn
into conflict because of climate-related
factors
like the melting of the himalayan
glaciers
and indian pakistan going to war or
india and china going to war or
we haven't discussed this but another
consequence of climate change
is the melting of the arctic and this is
leading to
competition between the us and russia
in particular for control of that area
so you go from disintegration of small
states to disintegration of medium-sized
states
to conflict between nuclear armed states
and
eventually to u.s conceivable u.s
involvement in climate-related
conflicts that would be the the latter
of escalation as i see it
and on top of that you would have
multiple disasters happening
simultaneously in the united states
of america which would require a massive
u.s military response so you have
you can envision in the military
certainly as as
thought it worries about this a time
when u.s forces are fully immobilized
and incapable of carrying out what they
see as their primary
defense tasks because they're divided
you know half their forces are engaging
in disaster relief in the united states
and and another half are in you know
dealing with these
multiple disasters in the rest of the
world
so i have a few a few
bullet points here that you could expand
upon or correct about
the the this ladder of escalation as you
describe it right so
at first um there's the the humanitarian
interventions where the the military is
running around to solve particular
uh humanitarian disasters like in
tacloban
uh then there's limited military
operations to support
allies there's disruptions to supply
chains and
the increase of failed states there's
conflict over resources there's internal
climate catastrophes and complex
catastrophes which you just mentioned
and then there's what you call climate
shock waves and and finally
all hell breaking loose where you have
you know multiple failed states tons of
mass migration
a situation in which no state uh
no matter how powerful is able to handle
climate shockwave would be a situation
where where you have multiple
extreme disasters occurring
simultaneously in different parts
of the world leading to a breakdown
in the supply chains that that keep
the world's economy afloat and keep food
and energy
supplies flowing around the world and
this is certainly a very real uh
possibility scientists are
speak of clusters of extreme events
and we've begun to see that we saw that
in 2017
when uh hurricane harvey was followed
immediately by hurricane irma
in florida and then hurricane maria in
the caribbean and puerto rico
and the u.s military responded to each
of those events
but had some difficulty moving
emergency supplies first from houston to
florida then to puerto rico
at the same time the west of the us
was burning up there were multiple
forest fires
out of control and the military was also
supplying emergency assistance of
california washington
state and oregon that's that's an
example
of a clusters of extreme events
now looking into the future
they're predicting scientists are
predicting
that uh this could occur in several
continents simultaneously
and as a result food supply chains would
break down
and uh the world
many parts of the world rely on grain
supply imported grain supplies
or other foodstuffs and imported energy
and in a situation like this you could
imagine
a shockwave a climate shock wave in
in in which trade just collapses
and entire states uh
suffer from a major catastrophe
food catastrophes uh leading to
state collapse and all that we've been
talking about
can you describe what all hell breaking
loses well my turn
this is my expression for or the all of
the above
scenario you have these multiple
disasters occurring
um and one that we have not discussed
uh at length is the threat to american
bases
and how that would uh impact
on the military so you have these
multiple disasters occurring
that uh require
that created demand on the military
to provide assistance domestically
like i say many areas needing emergency
assistance and not just of the
the obvious sort of handing out water
bottles
but as i say complex emergencies where
the military is being called in to
provide law and order to restore
infrastructure
to provide play the role of government
so you need large
uh capacity organizations to
to step in at the same time
it's being asked to do that in other
parts of the world
or to intervene in conflicts with
nuclear armed states
happening simultaneously but at the same
time
it can't its own bases have been
immobilized
by rising seas and
flooding and fires all of this is a very
realistic
scenario because parts of it have
already occurred
all right so let's make a little bit of
a pivot here
into something that you mentioned
earlier which is the melting of the
arctic
so i'm curious if you could explain the
geopolitical situation that arises from
the melting of an
of the art arctic ocean uh or sort of
the arctic region
uh that creates a new ocean that leads
to
arctic uh shipping lanes a new front to
defend
and resource competition for fish
minerals natural
gas and oil yes indeed
in a way the arctic is how the military
first got interested in climate change
especially the navy because the
navy never had much of an arctic
responsibility it was covered with ice
so it ships couldn't go there
except for submarines on on on
long-range
uh patrols under the sea ice but
navy never had to worry about the arctic
and then around 2009
uh the the the department of the navy
created a climate change
task force to address the consequences
of a melting arctic
sea ice and came to the
view that as you say this is a new ocean
that they would have to defend that
they'd never thought about before
and which for which they're not they
were not prepared
uh their ships were not equipped to
operate
for the most part in the arctic
uh ever since then uh the arctic has
become a major
geopolitical concern of the united
states
on multiple fronts uh but but
two two two or three points
in particular that needs to be noted
first of all
uh the melting of the ice cap makes it
possible
to extract uh resources from the area
oil and natural gas and it turns out
there's a lot of oil and natural gas
buried under the ice cap
under the uh seabed of the arctic
and oil and gas companies are very eager
to exploit those untapped reserves
so the area what was once considered
worthless
is now a valuable
prize and countries have exerted
claims to the area and some of these
claims overlap
so you have border disputes in the
arctic between russia
and the united states russia and norway
uh canada and and um
greenland great and and so on they're
they're now border disputes because
of the resources that are in these areas
and because of drilling occurring there
you now need to worry about
spills and um
and disasters occurring so that creates
a whole new
level of naval and coast guard
operations
in the arctic this is also led to
shipping lanes opening up into the
region and
who controls those shipping lanes
becomes a matter of interest
russia is trying to develop what it
calls the northern sea route
from uh the pacific to
the atlantic going across its northern
territory across siberia
and potentially this could save two
weeks of travel
for container ships moving from
rotterdam
say to shanghai and could be
commercially very important russia wants
to control that route
but but the u.s and other countries says
it's not yours to control
uh so you have disputes over the sea
routes
but then mo more important than any of
the above
is that russia has militarized
its portion of the arctic which is the
largest
portion and this has become a new
frontier for u.s russian military cooper
competition and there's been
um a huge increase in military exercises
base construction but so now from the
u.s point of view
the arctic is a new front
in the future war with russia and
they're training for this all the time
could you explain how the how the
bearing straight fits in
the bearing straight between the us
and russia is a pretty narrow space
um and that's the only way to get from
the north pacific
uh in into the arctic region
whether you're going to northern alaska
and northern canada
or to across uh from
from china and japan across the
northern sea route to to europe
uh so this becomes a strategic
passageway the way uh gibraltar
has been in the past and both the u.s
and russia are fortifying that
passageway and
there's constant uh uh
tussling going on there it doesn't get
reported much
but uh every other week or so
russia will send up its warplanes right
to the edge of u.s
airspace in that region
or the u.s will send its planes into
the edge of russian airspace to test
their
reflexes and there are naval maneuvers
happening
all the time so this has become seen as
a
important strategic place on the global
chessboard
how does climate change affect the the
bering strait
well it's it it affects it in the sense
that
it it's become the entry point to the
arctic
and the art climate changes made the
arctic
a place you want to go that it that it
wasn't before
all right so so so one point that you
made in your book that i'd like to
highlight
is the the arctic is seen as
a main place for conflict between the
great powers in the coming years
is that correct yes so for the us
and russia it's important uh here
where we would focus more on the barons
sea
uh the area uh above norway
and um
just it it helps of course have a map in
your mind but
russia shares the border with norway
and in its extreme north
and uh that part of russia
is the kola peninsula and
it's where the city of murmansk is
located
and that's the headquarters of russia's
northern fleet
and where it keeps its nuclear
missile submarines are based there
so that's how uh that's one of russia's
few
ways of access uh for
to into the atlantic ocean from its own
territory from its major
naval port at murmansk so the
waters uh adjacent to northern norway
and russia like the on the
on the other side uh have become a
strategic
very important strategic military
location
and the u.s has started uh building
uh military bases with norway
in that area close to the russian border
we've now stationed b-1 bombers in that
area
so it is seen as a
likely first area of
conflict in the event of a war between
the us and russia
is going to occur at that spot
uh and climate change
figures into this because russia views
its uh arctic region as critical
economically as well as strategically
and is building up its military forces
there
and and therefore from from a u.s nato
point of view it's a more strategically
important region but you ask about
china and china has become very
interested in the arctic
as a source of raw materials but also
as a strategic passageway
from its east coast to europe
for the reason i indicated if
once the ice cap melts uh they'll be
able to ship
uh goods to europe uh in much shorter
space of time and and bring goods back
if they can go through the arctic
but china also is very interested
in um in drilling
for energy in the arctic and for
minerals
there are a lot of valuable minerals
believed to be
in greenland and
you know you you can't get to those now
because
greenland is covered with ice but as
that ice melts
which it's doing at a rapid race rate
uh the ground is becoming exposed
and drill and mining activities have
begun there for
things like uranium and rare earths and
other valuable minerals and and china is
very deeply
interested in mining there and this has
led to
uh diplomatic uh maneuverings
then donald trump wants to talk about
buying greenland
uh uh uh to
to geopolitical competition between the
u.s and china over greenland
and and this area are are there any
ongoing proposals for how to
resolve uh territorial disputes in the
arctic
well the shorter answer is no there's
there's talk um there is something
called the arctic
council and uh
that this is an organization of the
states
that uh occupy territory
in the arctic region and it has some
very positive
environmental uh agendas
and is it had some success in
in addressing uh non-geopolitical issues
but it has not been given the authority
to address uh territorial disputes
that members have resisted that so you
don't have a um
it's it's not a forum that that would
provide for that
uh there is a mechanism
under the united nations convention on
the law of the
sea that allows for adjudication of
of uh offshore territorial disputes
and it's possible that that could be a
forum
for discussion but uh mostly these
disputes have remained unresolved
i i don't know much about this does that
have something to do with
like you know you have so many you have
x many miles from your
sea shelf or like you know
something having to do with like the
tectonic plates or
the ocean something i could expect yes
uh
so under the u.n convention on the law
of the
sea you're allowed a 200 nautical mile
exclusive economic zone off your
coastline
every any coastal country can claim 200
nautical miles
but you're also allowed an extra 150
miles
if you if you're uh
out of continental shelf if you can
prove
scientifically that your outer
continental
shelf extends beyond 200 nautical miles
then you can extend your eez
another 150 nautical miles out to 350
nautical miles
and the arctic the northern arctic
is has islands and territories
that have allowed
contending states to claim overlapping
eezs on this basis
and russia um has
claimed vast areas of the arctic
as part of its outer continental shelf
but uh the great imperial power of
denmark
which is territorially is one of the
largest imperial powers on earth because
it owns greenland
and greenland also has an
extended outer continental shelf
that overlaps with russia's
as does canada's you know you have to
picture the
looking down not on the kind of wall
maps we have
of the world in our classrooms
that make the arctic look huge but you
know from
from a global map everything comes
closer together
up there and so these
uh these extended
um eezs
overlap and so greenland
and canada and russia are all
claiming the north pole
okay so i think that paints really well
the picture of
the the already existing and you know
conflict there and how it will
likely only get get worse in terms of
the amount of
of conflict um it'd be great if we could
focus a bit on
uh nuclear weapons risk and climate
change in particular
so i i'm curious if you could explain
the
the dod's concerns of in improving china
and
a nuclear north korea and india and
pakistan
and other nuclear states um
in in this evolving situation of
increasing territorial disputes due to
to climate change so from a
nuclear from a nuclear war perspective
the two greatest dangers
i think uh uh and i've mentioned these
one one is the collapse of the
or the the disappearance of the
himalayan glaciers
sparking a war between india and china
that would go nuclear or one between
india and pakistan that would go nuclear
so that's one climate related
uh risk of nuclear escalation
the other is in the arctic
and here i i think the danger
is the fact that
russia uh has
uh turned the arctic into a major
stronghold for its nuclear weapons
capabilities
it stations a large share of of its
nuclear retaliatory
warheads on submarines
and other forces that are based in the
arctic
and so in the event of a conflict
between the us and russia um th
this could very well uh take place in
the arctic region
and trigger the use of nuclear weapons
as a consequence
i think we've done a really good job of
showing all the bad things that happen
as climate change gets worse so
the pentagon has perspective on
you know everything that we've covered
here is that correct
yes so how does the pentagon
intend to address the the issue of
climate change and how it affects its
operations
so the pentagon has multiple responses
to this and and this began
as early as 2010 in the quadrennial
defense review
of 2010. this is uh every four year
strategic blueprint released by the
joint chiefs of staff and then and the
department of
uh and the secretary of defense
um and that years was the first one that
number one identified climate change is
the national security threat
and and spelled out the responses that
the
military should make and and there were
three parts to that
uh one part is i guess you would call it
hardening
us bases to the impacts of climate
change
increasing resiliency and
sea walls to protect low-lying bases but
you know otherwise enhancing the
survivability
of u.s bases in the face of climate
change that's one response
a second response is in
mitigating the department's own
contributions to climate change by
uh by by by reducing its
reliance on fossil fuels and
to talk you know what specifically they
they're doing in that area and the third
is and i think this is very interesting
uh they said that um
we should not only that because climate
change is a global problem
this was specific climate change is a
global problem
it affects our allies and friends and
therefore
we should work with our allies and with
the
military forces of our allies and
friends
to do the same things we're doing at
home to do in their countries as well
that is to build resilience uh to
prepare for climate change to reduce
impacts uh so that this would be a
a global cooperative effort military to
military
uh which which has gotten very little
attention
i think in the in the from the media and
from
congress and elsewhere but but a very
important part of american foreign
policy
with respect to climate change so
there's hardening our own bases and
systems
um i believe in your book you mentioned
for example turning bases into
uh like operational islands such that
their energy and material needs are
disconnected from
supply lines um so and
and the the second was you know reducing
the greenhouse emissions of the military
and the third is helping allies
with with such efforts so i i'm curious
if you could describe a bit more
the the first and the second of these
the hardening of our own systems and
bases
and uh becoming more green
because i mean it is interesting and at
least a little bit surprising that the
military is trying to become green
in order to improve combat readiness
through
independence of through independence of
uh
foreign uh and domestic uh fuel
needs and sources so could you could you
explain a little bit more
this um you know for example the
the drive to create a green fleet in the
navy
sure now um
this this this began during the obama
administration
and then when semi underground during
the trump
administration so the the information we
we have is is mainly pre-trump
now uh under
president biden climate change has been
elevated to a national security threat
as per an executive order he issued
shortly after taking office
and our new secretary of defense lloyd
austin
has said has issued a a
complimentary statement that climate
change is
a departmental wide
department of defense concern so
um activities that were prohibited
by the trump administration will now be
revived
so we will now hear a lot more about
this
and in the months ahead but there is a
four-year blackout of
information on on
what was being done but uh during the
obama administration
uh the department of defense was ordered
to um as
as i say to work on on
adaptation and mitigation both
as part of its responsibilities the
adaptation
uh affected particularly bases
in low-lying coastal areas and there are
a lot of
a lot of u.s bases for historic purposes
for historic reasons are located along
the east coast of the us
that that's where they started out uh
most important of them is the norfolk
naval station
in virginia the most uh the most
important naval base
in the in the united states it's at
it's at sea level and it's on
on basically reclaims swamp lands
and it's subsiding into the ocean at the
same time sea level is rising
but there are many other bases along the
east coast
um in florida and in the gulf coast
that are at equal risk and so
part of what the military is doing
is to build sea walls to
protect them against sea surges
moving critical equipment from
areas that are in high flood prone areas
to areas that are at higher elevation
adopting codes any new buildings built
on these bases
have to be hardened against hurricanes
and
sensitive equipment electronic equipment
has to be
put in the higher stories so that if
there are flooded they won't be
damaged so there's a lot of
very uh you know concrete
measures uh that have to do with
base construction that have been
undertaken
to to enhance the um resilience of bases
in the in response to extreme storms and
flooding uh so that's one one
aspect of this the mitigation
aspect is to reduce reliance on fossil
fuels
and to convert as wherever possible
vehicles air ground and sea vehicles
to use alternative fuels
so the navy the army the air force
are converting their non-tactical
vehicle fleets these they all have huge
numbers of ordinary
sedans and vans and trucks
uh increasingly these will be hybrids or
electric vehicles and
the air force is experimenting with
alternative fuels
produced by algae the
and the navy has experimented with
alternative uh fuels
derived uh from from agricultural
products
and so on so there's a lot of
experimentation going on
a lot of some of the biggest
solar arrays in the us are
on u.s military bases or
constructed um at the behest
of u.s military bases by by by private
energy companies
so those are some of the activities that
are underway
so in addition to threatening
u.s military bases and the the basis of
our allies
climate change will also affect the
safety and security of
for example biosafety
level 4 labs and
also nuclear power plants so i'm curious
how you view
the the risks of
climate change affecting you know
crucial infrastructure should it
you know should it fail could create
global catastrophe for example from
you know nuclear power plants melting
down or
pathogens being released from biosafety
labs that
that fail under the stresses of climate
change
i have not seen the literature on the
bio labs in the pentagon literature
what they do worry about is
the fragility of the u.s
energy infrastructure
in particular in part because they
depend on the same
energy infrastructure as we do
uh for their energy needs for
electricity transmission
pipelines and the like to supply their
bases
and and their other facilities and
they're very aware uh that uh the u.s
energy infrastructure is exceedingly
vulnerable
to climate change uh either
uh a lot of it a a very large part of
of our infrastructure is on the east
coast
and the west coast very close to sea
level very
um exposed to a storm damage
and a lot of it is just just fragile
so a clearer example of that is
hurricane maria and puerto rico when
when the um the electric system
collapsed entirely and the
army corps of engineers had to come in
and were there for almost an entire
year rebuilding the energy
infrastructure
of puerto rico up they've had to do this
in other places as well
so they're very worried that
climate change disasters multiple
disasters
will knock out the power in the u.s
causing a major you know
cascading failures so when when energy
fails
then um petrochemical facilities
fail and that's what happened in houston
in hurricane harvey the
with the power failure went out and
these petrochemical facilities
which houston has many of failed
and uh toxic chemicals spilled out
and also the sewer system collapsed
so you you have with cascading failures
producing toxic threat um and the
military
um had to issue toxic
uh clothing
protective clothing to its personnel
in doing rescue operations because the
water
in in flooded areas of houston was
poisonous
um so it's it's the the
cascading effects that they worry about
this happened in new york city with
hurricane sandy
in 2012 where
power went out then energy said then gas
stations couldn't operate
and hospitals and nursing homes couldn't
um uh
well i'm going on here but you get a
sense of the
interrelationship between these
uh critical elements of infrastructure
fires are another aspect of this as we
know from california
um a lot of u.s bases
um in california are at risk from fires
uh and the transmission lines that
that um carry them carry the energy
i was going to mention the colonial
pipeline
disaster which was uh which was a
cyber attack not climate related
but that that uh exposes
the degree to which our uh
energy infrastructure is uh
fragile yeah i mean if it if it rains or
snows
just enough you know we've all
experienced losing power for six hours
or more the energy grid seems very
fragile even to
relatively normal weather yes
but with climate change and these
multiple simultaneous disasters
where the whole systems break
down do you see lethal autonomous
weapons
uh as fitting into the risks of
escalation in a world stressed by by
climate change
well i see lethal autonomous weapons as
a major
issue and problem which i've written
about and i
worry about a great deal now what is
their relationship
to climate change i i couldn't say
uh i think you know the military in
general
is facing a world
in which they feel that humans
are increasingly unable to cope
with the demands of
time compression and decision making and
the complexity of the environment
in which decision makers have to operate
and that's uh partly technological
it's it's partly just the complexity of
the world that we've been discussing
and so there's a ever-increasing
sense among the military
that commanders have to be
provided with uh computer
assisted decision making and
um autonomous operations
uh because they can't process the amount
of data that's
that's coming into them uh
simultaneously
this is behind not just autonomous
weapon systems but autonomous weapon
systems
decision making the new
plans for
how the army navy and air force will
operate
will be fewer human decision makers
and more machine decision make process
information processors and decision
makers
in which humans will be given a
a menu of possible choices
uh but but they will be you know strike
this set of targets or that set of
targets
but not stop and think about this and
you know maybe we should de-escalate
they're they're they're going to be
militarized
options so
some sense of lethal autonomous weapons
is potentially
exacerbating the or catalyzing the speed
at which the ladder of escalation
um is is moved through
no question about it uh
you know many factors are contributing
to that
uh uh the um speed
of weaponry the introduction of
hypersonic
missiles which cuts down flight time
from
you know 30 minutes to five minutes
the fact that uh wars are being
conducted in what they call
multiple domains simultaneously cyber
space air sea and ground
um that no commander can
know what's happening in all of those
domains
and make decisions so you have to have
what what they want to create a super
brain
called the joint or domain command and
control system
the jad c2
system which will collect
uh data from sensors all over the planet
and you know and and and compress it
into simplified uh
simplified uh assessments of what's
happening
and then tell commanders you know here
are your choices
one two and three and you have five
seconds to choose
um and uh you know
if not we'll pick the best one and we'll
be linked directly to the fireworks
and to to to launch weapons
this is what the future will look like
and they're testing this now it's called
project convergence
so so how do you see
all of this affecting the risks of
uh human extinction and of
existential risks i'm deeply
concerned about this
inclination to rely more on machines to
make
decisions of life and death for the
planet i think everybody should be
worried about this
and i don't think enough attention is
being paid to these
to these um dangers of automating
uh life and death decision making
uh but but but this is moving ahead very
rapidly
and and i i think it does pose enormous
risks
the reason that i'm so worried is
that um i think
the uh computer-assisted decision-making
will have a bias towards military
actions you know humans
are imperfect and sometimes
we make mistakes sometimes we
get angry and we we go in the direction
of being more violent and brutal
there's no question about that but we
also have a capacity to say stop wait a
minute this is something wrong
here and maybe we should think twice
and hold back and that saved us
on a number of occasions from nuclear
extinction
um i i recommend the book gambling
with armageddon by martin sherwin a new
a new account of the cuban missile
crisis
a day-by-day hour by our account in
in which it was clear that that uh
the us and russia came very close
very extremely close to starting a
nuclear war
in 1962 and you know
somebody you know said
wait a minute let's just think about
this let's not rush into this
let's let's give it a another 24 hours
to see if we can come up with a solution
um adly stevenson
apparently played a key role in this i
fear
that the machines we designed are not
going to have
that kind of thinking built into them
that kind of hesitancy that
second thinking i think the machines are
going to be
um designed you know the algorithms that
that that are that are inhabit them are
are going to reflect the the most
aggressive
possible outcomes and that's why i
uh fear that we move closer to
human extinction in a crisis than before
and because the time of decision making
is going to be
so compressed that humans are are going
to have
very little chance uh to think about
this
so so how do you view the interplay of
climate change and autonomous weapons is
affecting
existential risk
climate change is just going to make
everything on the planet more
stressful you know is in general
it's it's going to create a lot of
stress a lot of
catastrophes occurring simultaneously
and creating a lot of
risk events happening that people are
going to have to be dealing with
and they're going to create a
a lot of choices hard
difficult choices let's say you're the
president
you're the commander-in-chief and you
have
multiple hurricanes striking and fires
striking the united states that's hardly
uh an unlikely outcome uh
at the same time that there's a a
crisis with china and russia occurring
uh you know where where where where work
would be a possible outcome you know
there's a naval clash at
sea in the south china sea or
something happening on the ukraine
border and meanwhile nigeria is breaking
apart
and india and pakistan are at the verge
of war
these are very likely
situations in another 10 or 20 years if
climate change proceeds the way it is
uh so you're just the the complexity of
the environment
the stress that people will be under
the decisions they're going to have to
make swiftly
between do we save miami
or uh do we save um
tokyo uh do we save los
angeles or do we save new york or do we
save
london where we only have so many
resources
uh in these conditions the the
i think the inclination is going to be
to rely more on machines
to make decisions and to carry out
actions
and that i think has inherent dangers in
it
do you and or the pentagon have a
timeline
for you know how how much and
how fast is the instability from climate
change coming
this is a progression i mean we're on
that path
so there's no point at which you could
say we've reached
that level uh it's just an
ever-increasing level of stress
yeah how do you how do you see the world
in five or ten years given the path that
we're currently on
i'm pessimistic about this
and the reason i'm pessimistic is
because
if you go back and read the first very
first
reports of the intergovernmental panel
on climate change the ipcc
their very first reports and they would
give
a series of
you know based on their estimates of the
pace
of uh of um greenhouse gas emissions
if they go this high then you have these
projections
if they go higher than these projections
out to you know 2030 24 to 2050 we've
all seen these charts
so if you go back to the first ones um
basically we're living in 2021
uh what they said were the worst case
projections for 2040 to 2050
by and large uh so
we we're moving into the danger zone
so what i'm saying is we we're moving
into the danger zone
much much faster than the most
worst case scenarios that
scientists were talking about 10 years
ago and 20 years ago
and if that's the case uh then then we
we should be very very worried about the
pace at which this
is occurring because we're off the
charts now
from those earlier predictions of how
rapidly
sea level rise was occurring
desertification was occurring heat waves
uh
we we're living in a 2050 world now
so where are we going to be in a 20 20
30
when we're going to be in a 2075 world
and that world
you know was a pretty damn scary world
all right so i i'm mindful of the time
here so
just a few more questions about
messaging would be would be nice
do you think that tying existential
risks to
national security issues would benefit
the movement towards reducing
existential risks
given that climate change is elevated in
some sense by
the dod taking it seriously on account
of national security
so let me explain why i wrote this book
you know and it's this is very much a
product of the trump era
but it's i think it's still true today
that you have a country that's divided
between environmentalists and
climate deniers and
and this divide has prevented
forward movement in congress to pass
legislation that will make a significant
difference in this country
and you know and i believe you have to
have
this has to come from from national
level
the kind of changes we need the mass of
investments
in renewables and
charger charging stations for electric
vehicles
all these things require national
leadership and right now that's
impossible because of the
fundamental divide between the democrats
and republicans
or denialist environmentalists however
you want to put it
some of my friends in the environmental
community
dear friends think if if we could only
get across the message
that things are getting worse you know
that those
dinars will finally wake up uh
and change their views i don't think
that's going to happen
i i think appeal you know more
scientific
evidence about climate change is not
going to win over more people
we've tried that uh we we
we've done everything we can to make the
scientific evidence
known uh so
the way to win i i believe that the
the military perspective that this is a
threat to the national security of the
united states of america
are you a patriotic american or not do
you care about the security of this
country
or not this is not a matter of
environmentalism
or anti-environmentalism this is about
the national security of this country
where do you stand on that that this is
a third approach
that could possibly win over some
segment of that population that until
now has resisted
uh action on climate change that's
not going to listen to an
environmentalist a green argument
there is evidence that that this
approach
is making a difference that republicans
who um won't even talk about the causes
of climate change
uh but who ac knowledge that
uh their communities are at risk
or the country is at risk on a on a
national security basis
and therefore are willing to invest in
some of the changes that are necessary
for that reason so uh i do believe
that um making this argument uh
it could win over enough
uh of of that that resistant population
um to make it possible to actually
achieve forward momentum
do you think that relating climate
change to migration
issues is helpful for messaging
i'm not sure because uh
i think people who are opposed to
migration
don't care what the cause is
i do think but i do think that
it might make it feed
into the argument that i was just making
that uh our security
would be better off by emphasizing
climate change
and therefore taking steps to reduce
the pressures that lead climate migrate
migrants to migrate
now the military certainly takes that
view
so um it could be helpful
but i i i think it's a difficult topic
all right so given everything we've
we've discussed here today
how would you how would you characterize
and
and summarize the pentagon's interest
view and action on climate change and
why that matters
so now now we have a new test because
um as i've indicated we had a blackout
period
of four years during the trump
administration when all of this was
hidden and couldn't be discussed
so we don't know how much was
accomplished
now this is an explicit priority for the
department of defense
and the defense budget and
and other documents say that uh this is
a pri
priority for the department in the armed
forces
and they are required to take steps
to um to to
adapt to climate change and to mitigate
their
role in climate change
uh so we have to see
how much actually is accomplished
in this new period before really you can
you can make any definitive assessment
but i think that
um you can see that the language
adopted by the biden administration
and lloyd austin at the
department of defense is so much
stronger
and more vigorous than what the pentagon
was saying in the
obama administration so even though
there was a four-year blackout period
uh there was a learning curve going on
and what they're saying today is is much
more
advanced in the sense of recognizing the
severity
of the risk posed by climate change and
the necessity of making this a priority
all right so as we wrap up are there any
final words
or anything you'd like to share that you
feel is is left unsaid or any parting
words for the
audience as i started out
um you know we mustn't
we mustn't forget that if you if you
asked anybody in the military what their
job is
they're always they're going to come
back to china number one so
we we shouldn't forget that defending
against china
it's only after you peel away the layers
of you know how they're going to operate
in a climate-altered world that all of
these other concerns start spilling out
but it's not going to be the first thing
that they're likely to say uh i
i think that has to be clear you know
based on
on my conversations but there is a real
awareness
that in fact climate change is going to
have an immense impact on the operations
of
of the military in the years ahead and
that its impact is going to grow
exponentially
all right well thank you very much for
for coming on michael
and for for sharing all of this with us
i really appreciated your book and
i recommend others check it out as well
it's all hell
breaking loose um i think it does a
really good job of showing the way in
which
the ways in which you know the world is
going to get worse through climate
change
there's a lot of really great examples
in there so
also the the audiobook has a really
great narrator
which i very much liked so yeah thank
you very much for coming on if people
want to
check or follow you out on social media
where and how can they do that
oh i'm at michaelclair.com
and um and it's
well that's for that let's start there
all right uh
do you also have a place where you where
you list publications
that site at that site okay all right
and it's
k-l-a-r-e michael claire k-l-a-r-e
all right thank you very much michael